[Música]
en febrero de 2020 el diseñador de moda
que en dota cada está a punto de cumplir
81 años asiste al desfile de la marca
que sigue llevando su nombre
[Música]
tú eres contra ellos
es genial estoy muy contento la
colección es elegante relajada y al
mismo tiempo estructurada
unos meses más tarde en octubre de 2020
que en su cumbre frente a lakovic 19 nos
deja como herencia su manera de pensar
el presente esta alma rebelde con sus
impresiones florales y sus fiestas
endiabladas supo como ningún otro
compartir los años revolucionarios de
1970 pero hoy el ambiente es diferente
el diseñador felipe oliveira baptista el
sexto en reemplazarlo a la cabeza de
kenzo desde que él
compró la marca prefiere mencionar una
catástrofe actual la destrucción de las
abejas porque hoy en día la moda no
puede evitar tener en cuenta los cambios
que agitan nuestras sociedades
la gente mira el mundo como un bebé como
si fuese la primera vez que lo ven y la
gente tiene la impresión de que por fin
se puede escapar y ver el mundo y creo
que es importante que ellos se reflejen
nuestro arte y fue lo que se hizo no
puedo asistir a muchos desfiles esta
temporada pero creo que todos estuvieron
influenciados por el confinamiento todos
fuimos influenciados
respetando las reglas sanitarias y a
pesar de la ausencia de compradores
internacionales algunas marcas como dior
pusieron en escena desfiles para
presentar sus colecciones verano 2021
no sé hasta tal vez un año que no he
visto un desfile de moda y así como en
venecia cuando hacía parte del jurado en
la mostra este año ha sido impactante
venir a una sala de cine con extraños
frente a una pantalla volvía a sentir
ese placer que había olvidado
estoy esperando vivir un placer inédito
verde renacer es el placer de ver un
desfile de moda con mis ojos porque se
trata de un espectáculo viviente no hay
que olvidarlo me parece importante que
incluso en las crisis sanitarias no se
olvida el arte tampoco es casi por eso
que línea la fashion mujer para poder
hablar sobre la cultura en la casa dior
maria gràcia cure y sigue colaborando
con artistas feministas estos carteles
de escenografía que imitan la forma de
vitrales góticos son en realidad collage
de palabras y de reflexiones sobre la
condición femenina una obra de lucia
marcucci artista vanguard
la colección se inspira de la realizada
en japon por christian dior para el
otoño-invierno 1957 un cruce de técnicas
arquitectónicas propias del diseñador
parisino y de la fluidez de las telas
japonesas
maría gracias reflexiona sobre el hecho
de que la ropa haga más parte de la
esfera privada que pública
porque en wisconsin mind distinguida
davis time probably wifi de tu vida tú
te quedas falsa en su problema
our conversation midauar por ti he
recordado esto porque creo que en este
momento sentimos probablemente que
debemos cuidarnos y por lo tanto la
conversación que sostenemos con nuestro
cuerpo y la ropa es más personal también
está esta idea superficial según la cual
la moda sólo es para los ricos sólo es
diversión es un verdadero trabajo el
textil hace parte de la cultura de la
humanidad no hay que olvidar a penélope
work
en el esparto humanity cultura cuidando
tu forma de penélope
la astuta penélope cien veces sobre el
oficio volvía a poner su obra todos los
actores de la moda hoy toman conciencia
de que hay que mirar el presente de
frente
sí
diría que es circunstancial a la moda y
los diseñadores de moda fue lo que
ocurrió en el pasado con christian dior
o fue lo que ocurrió con its anglogold
cuando es realizada por diseñadores
estamos en el transformarse en la
anticipación en la conquista de una
nueva forma de futuro que responde a
nuevas necesidades nuevos desafíos of
the kid
[Música]
el nigeriano kennedy diseñó su colección
en lagos durante el confinamiento es la
segunda vez que elige parís para
compartir su experiencia y no es un azar
[Música]
era algo difícil
incluso saltar esa temporada pero me
dije no no puedo abandonar a la gente
con la que trabajo soy queer en nigeria
no se permite hacer cuidado es imposible
por ejemplo porque no puedo pedirle a un
hombre que se maquilla el rostro en
lagos de donde vengo porque no puedo
pedirle a un hombre que se pinta las
uñas y la policía me detiene y me
pregunta por qué me pinto las uñas dicha
razón es un mensaje para la gente de mi
país es como si les escribiera una carta
quiero que la gente que normalmente debe
cuidarnos el presidente la policía
quiero que vean esto y empiecen a pensar
de una manera nueva y diferente
a mi juicio ese mes es bajo
la moda ciertamente no es futilidad ni
nimiedad ni frivolidad
[Música]